another big part of pathology that
you know most people know about is
doing autopsies like we're the people
who do the autopsies i don't do them now
in my current job but that's something i
had to do in my training and i learned
how to do it and uh wait you've done
autopsies i've done 70
have you ever done any while listening
to this show no that was uh because i
did those autopsies back when i was
training so your podcast was not on
wasn't on yet yeah so you were just
you're watching uh old episodes of
gilligan's island
um
you were watching reruns of the office
while you were
deep owning someone listen uh yamane
uh i'm fascinated uh by autopsies i'm a
very ghoulish man
yeah i'm fascinated by it what's it like
to do an autopsy can you just i mean
first of all did you completely start to
disassociate yourself from the fact that
this is a person at a certain point are
you just working with what feels to you
like a piece of furniture i mean
not not a piece of furniture but i mean
you you have to like not have emotions
when you're doing it because you want to
do a good job yeah yeah
like a piece of furniture no i'm saying
i'm not
listen i'm just i'm first of all by
interview in interviewing you yes i am
opening up a window into my soul which
is that i don't really connect with
humans
it's actually interesting when i when i
walked into my first autopsy i thought i
was gonna throw up i thought i was gonna
be nervous i thought i was gonna hate it
but i was completely fine so maybe maybe
i'm a sociopath
yeah but you know what we need
sociopaths in entertainment we need them
in entertainment almost exclusively and
we also need them in the fields of
pathology and medicine yeah exactly so
um but yeah you just
you know like you focus
on one organ at a time and
you forget everything how often can you
look at the person on the table and
pretty much guess what happened i mean
if a lamp post is sticking through their
chest
you know right yes i'm guessing the lamp
post going through his chest at 80 miles
an hour that's probably probably killed
that was probably what killed him for
her but if are there times when you look
at the body and go like this i feel like
this is going to be the heart or i'm
pretty sure it's going to be the liver i
mean most of the ones that i did were
like hard and you have to open the body
and look through every organ to figure
out what caused a
person's death because
you know autopsies are divided into
forensic and medical so forensic
autopsies are done at the medical
examiner office and you know the ones
that they show on csi but obviously not
not real life autopsies are not like
that
a lot more crude
a lot i see a lot fewer answers you know
like i see you know the these tv shows
show you these autopsies as if it's like
the magic uh
thing that will give you all the answers
it's it's not like that
you mean so there are a lot of autopsies
where that's just inconclusive exactly a
lot of them yes so so and i and then i
did what i did mostly were medical
autopsies so someone dies at home
without anyone you know witnessing that
or someone dies within a few hours of
being admitted to the hospital so you
need to figure out why they died so now
i'm going to stick to this point you're
saying many autopsies are inconclusive
yes
definitely you're meaning
we're right a murder
oh of course we're going here of course
yes there's a good chance i wouldn't be
cut because many autopsies are
inconclusive unless you did it with a
lamp post yeah no but what i'm saying is
i think we've been taught by these crime
shows that we watch forensic files for
example but if there's any foul play the
odd the coroner is going to catch you
that's true you're making it very clear
to me right now that no i have like a 70
chance of getting away with it if
i'm somewhat clever is that what you're
saying and is that what you're saying to
my listeners as well
and is that what you're saying on the
record the record and uh something that
can be taken to the state licensure
board to the court
yeah
we also would like you to sue yourself
yeah so yeah report myself sue myself
and just lock myself up and uh you're a
very uh chipper guy who's destroying his
own career
in front of us
and while laughing which is um have you
ever yes have you ever been doing an
autopsy
and you're you're down there and you're
in the chest cavity and then you look up
almost to a camera that's not there and
said
this was murder
have you ever done that i wish
you wish do you want to do it right now
you could look down and then look right
up to us and say and say and tell us how
you would do it yaman say this was
murder
all right so i'm like going through the
chest and i like to take take out the
heart
this is murder
that's good
that's fantastic really good come on
that was really good okay
that was a whole new heart like that
yeah i love that you held it up to the
light and you went yeah this is murder
i still prefer the past tense this was
murder but that's fine
sorry i think what yaman is saying is he
just ripped the heart out of the
liverpool
the guy was in there for an infected
tooth yes
he thought you were a dentist
you pulled his heart out of his chest
and said this is murder which
um wow that is fascinating